we gotta talk about president corn julio
oh yeah we do so i tweeted this whoever
did this should be ashamed how
disrespectful to our president
so uh here's joe biden with b was his
head and frozen aren't familiar with
what cornholio is on beavers and
butthead one of the best shows ever of
course by mike judge bevis when he had
too much caffeine would pull his shirt
over his head hold his arms to his side
at a 90 degree angle with fists and he
would say he was the great cornholio joe
biden did that he literally did he
literally did it and i don't know why
but i will say this before we talk about
just joe biden going off of what we're
talking about twitter and the silliness
there's a reason why i tweeted whoever
did this should be ashamed how
disrespectful to our president it's
because i wanted to share the image
because it's hilarious but i also wanted
to make it so the media had a difficult
time claiming i supported it because
often what they'll do is
when i tweet something out like with the
alec baldwin thing
i said alec baldwin is responsible they
started saying tim poole wants him
arrested and charged and i'm like i
never said any of that stuff i just said
ultimately you know when it comes to
guns you're responsible it's in your
hand so here
oh no i was criticizing this image of
joe biden as beavis see you see you know
i just post the image i don't give a
damn yeah but like you know so look we
we uh uh we've got the zeppelin coming
um the the famous story you guys
probably don't know everyone else knows
i'm sorry if you hear me tell the story
but for you guys wikipedia claimed
because of some article i invented a
zeppelin that would fly around live
streaming and it was just like insane
because i never did i did work with
drones and so from that i got someone
speculated something wrote about a like
a whiteboard idea we might have had
wikipedia for a year said i invented a
zeppelin
they finally removed it they wouldn't
remember they said i wasn't reliable
even though i said i never invented it
and so uh you know you and i were
talking we're like let's do it so you
know ian's been helping set this project
up where we're actually we have the
zeppelin it's coming it's gonna be here
in like a week or two and then we're
gonna retroactively make wikipedia
correct so i'll have to redo it so i i
look at how the media is fundamentally
broken how they shill for someone like
biden and i understand how they do
things why they do things and
understanding how these these people in
the establishment don't understand jokes
you really can just manipulate their
ability to do certain things so in this
instance
it's a tweet of me saying that it's you
should be ashamed for disrupting the
president i would say uh i think the
country would be better off with a
beavis presidency than currently what we
have right now would abide in presidency
that would be my caption but that's hey
that's just me ian what do you think
about president beavis
uh well we would have toilet paper yeah
guaranteed
i have a lot of thought i feel like the
reason i haven't been talking is because
i feel like i'm going to be a wet
blanket if i start talking right now i
feel like text is is so dangerous and
can be used as a weapon speech as well
but in this instance we still don't
understand the power of text out of
context especially out of context and
text
if you don't if
satire like you were saying earlier be
careful don't give them any ideas like
if you if you make satire like hey the
the oligarchs are coming for me then
whoa you're putting that out there and
they're gonna be like now's our chance
so that that at me was actually pretty
funny though bieber's as president yeah
what uh newsweek said is the imaginary
jet pack
when so newsweek wrote an article about
the five strange moments you may you
might have missed the first thing i'll
say is you might have missed it because
nobody watched it the ratings were
apparently like nightmarish i didn't
even know what happened i didn't i
didn't either i had no clue
luke was watching some like what some
like army movie or something i was
watching like history of the roman
empire way better which isn't amazing
you don't even know what he's doing how
does cnn have the authority to do this
given what they've been doing in terms
of putting out garbage news how do they
get the authority to have a town hall
with biden
i don't know and biden wanted to do it
but there's a couple other things too
there was a point where biden said that
corporations aren't paying a cent and
then he like made the okay sign and
looked through it and then started
whispering for dramatic effect or
something
there was obviously he said that he
raced colin powell and that colin powell
uh he only he says well i only won
i won only because he was where i was
going to crash into him i think that's
actually an accurate statement i'd be
scared he would crash into me as well so
thank you
he misspeaks on taiwan this one wasn't
that strange but it was kind of funny
biden said if china attacks taiwan we
will intervene and the white house was
like stop don't say that
and then the last one was the last one
he forgets the name of the long beach
port now this
i'm going to read you this quote
and i want you to take it in
quote
40 of all products coming i'm sorry i'm
gonna start over this is from joe biden
and i want it really to sink in quote
forty percent of all products coming
into the united states of america on the
west coast go through los angeles and
what am i doing here
what
wow
cooper
that's it what am i doing here
and then cooper interjected not to say
uh not to press him on his inability to
finish a sentence or properly govern but
to give him the answer because that's
typically what you have the you know an
adversarial media do is fill in the
answers for the for the for the
president who can't finish a sentence
what am i doing here
what am i saying here where am i going
here that's what he meant i'll give him
the benefit of the doubt if it were the
first i don't i don't i i think the
problem is the media does that so when
joe biden says trinidad i shop at a
pressure the media like i'll give you a
better example because that one's silly
that one's pretty good though joe biden
will say something like
we you know uh americans
we gotta come on you know we gotta uh
raise taxes on the one percent and the
media will say joe biden said to raise
taxes on the one percent they won't show
you that he struggled to speak he said
he's standard they'll put quotes in
place and they'll put we dot dot
americans dot dot need to tax dot dot
the one percent dot dot because i have
to cut out all of the things where he's
screwing up if the dude literally says
what am i doing here that's not
something you normally say you'd go like
this
here's what i'd say
40 of all products coming into the us on
the west coast west coast go through la
and uh uh what's what's the other one
long beach they go through long beach i
wouldn't i wouldn't go what am i doing
here
now if you're a senile old man yeah
you'd say what am i doing here and then
i got to tell you if if if that were me
with biden cooper interjected is it long
beach long beach thank you i'd respond
with oh mr president you're you're on
television live doing a town hall
is everything all right whatever state
he's in every state if it were the first
fifth tenth time it but it's systematic
and it is it is
uh you can't ignore it it's it's out
there and everybody knows it's just
nobody's talking about it i mean we talk
about it this is a funny thing you guys
see the clip with barry weiss on c on
cnn with brian stelter of course
you see you see that so barry weiss
she's doing she's been doing a pretty
good job i would say she's been doing a
pretty great job actually calling out
the stuff and she was on cnn and she was
like look at all the stuff that's going
on with crt in schools and we can't talk
about it we're not allowed and then
brian's others like what do you mean not
allowed people talk about it all the
time and it's like no brian you don't
you never talk about it you lie you get
in the periphery you ignore it he gave
10 seconds to andy know when andy noe
got beaten by antifa because he had to
he didn't do a segment on the on the on
the dangerous journalists face so no
people don't talk about it well no i
mean a classic example of this is the
cal rittenhouse case so people who've
seen the video know the facts know he's
innocent however if you talk to the
average kenosha juror they don't know
that 60 of them presume he's guilty and
the reason why they presume he's guilty
is because of mainstream media it's why
we have to go through an extensive jury
selection process in the two weeks just
to get what he's constitutionally
entitled to a presumed instant jury we
got this tweet great tweet paul paul
begala oh my gosh that sound you hear is
the shattering of the right wing myth
about potus not being sharp his wit
command of details personal engagement
are impressive he's clearly on the top
of his game not even recommending that
folks inject bleach but now here's
here's the thing i read this not knowing
who this guy was i would think this was
satire if i did not know it was not the
baby you know i know pablo gale
we talked i worked in the clinton white
house in the summer of 1993. but
gallagher used to be an old-school
populist he used to be indistinguishable
from steve bannon wow he got a lot of
money became a corporate corporate you
know well whatever language you can use
on youtube yes
so trump never told people to inject
bleach
of course not it was all nonsense i mean
it was a ridiculous uh exaggeration now
partially trump could have handled
aspects of that better but it's just
they need to live in their own world to
such a degree they have to now create
their own world and it's going to
backfire over time i got a little flack
for being a little critical of trump on
that video where i said when his excuse
was that it was sarcasm was probably not
the right word for what he was intending
to do there right yeah but um i swear to
you that could be as easily parody as
seriousness could you could you click on
his uh profile so he could read the um
bios and uh he didn't know oh he's not
gonna let me out he used to be james
carvel's partner okay back in the day oh
did he really oh yeah yeah he helped
harris wofford win in 1991 235 000
followers author if you're fired the
perfect guide to beating donald trump
cnn contributor counselor for president
clinton dopey flunky according to trump
oh well yes that's true he is now
dopamine so i i look
joe biden's town hall he started his
profile picture he stuttered he
stammered he was all over the place he
voted i know i i know who he is but he's
vaccinated too biden did not come off as
strong
the the cornholio thing was weird enough
it was very weird because i thought i
thought someone froze framed it freeze
frame right and i didn't realize the
video was still running i think he may
have been seizing we're having a stroke
oh so i mean that's what that's why
rogan said there's no way he took the
actual shot because they're like you
watch this guy you want to give him a
shot and you want to see what what he
might do how he might react online well
there's a number of reasons why i don't
think he took the shot and i agree with
rogan it's because there's too much risk
if he actually did because there are
people who have adverse reactions to it
there are people who do take it and pass
out so so if you're at the white house
pr and when you have yeah if you're
doing the white house pr be like okay
give them the shot later maybe but give
them give them some fake shots because
the risk the risk is too overwhelming
for them to take and they would never
take that risk i get the idea i just
disagree i think the simple solution
tend to be the correct one joe biden was
on a sound stage they controlled the
feed they could have given him the shot
and then they could they just turn it
off afterwards anyway
but there was journalists there right oh
come on in the room yeah a lot of them
would have covered it up journalists
having heard both sorry sorry the
government establishment repeaters that
regurgitate all the diarrhea and hot
trash that the government gives them
yeah now i was learning about caligula
today he's the mad emperor
in the roman empire and he suffered a
brain injury uh but before his brain
injury he was actually known as a really
great emperor as a really great leader a
people person who gave the people what
they wanted was very diplomatic was very
smart then he had this weird brain
injury and then he went crazy he went
mad he went through he made his horse
extremely exactly he went through
he did a lot of things we came and
mentioned on this show if this was a
family-friendly show but but he had
cognitive decline and utterly created
chaos throughout the entire roman empire
which and as as i'm watching this as i'm
learning this i'm like holy cow now we
have a presidency that clearly the
president is going through a major
cognitive decline
clearly the man has two brain stints
inside of his head right now as we're
speaking clearly he's not all there and
we have utter chaos all around us thanks
for checking out this segment from the
tim cast irl podcast if you want to
watch live you can check out this
channel monday through friday at 8 00 pm
and don't forget to smash that like
button subscribe to this channel and if
you want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you